[MUSIC PLAYING]
IAN NI-LEWIS: If you develop
Android with Lint warnings
turned on, you've
probably seen at least one
or two warnings
about allocations
in drawing routines.
Why is that?
I mean, everybody knows that
allocations have a cost,
but why be so worried about
draw time allocations,
in particular?
What makes them so special?
My name is Ian
Ni-Lewis, and I'm going
to show you what makes
onDraw allocations different
and why you should be
worried about them.
First, let's state the obvious.
onDraw runs on the UI
thread, and any extra work
on the UI thread is bad.
Now, allocations are cheap,
but they're not free,
and there's always
a small chance
that an allocation is
going to block, especially
when you're low on memory.
Now, calling a blocking
method from the UI thread
is a terrible idea.
But that applies to any method
that runs on the UI thread,
right?
Message handlers, lifecycle
methods, you name it.
Why is onDraw different?
Well, for one, there's
the sheer number of times
that onDraw gets called.
But we want it to be called
at least 60 times per second,
right?
So the cost of
any work in onDraw
is going to be magnified
by that frequency.
But allocations are
especially problematic.
You see, a high
rate of allocations
is going to lead
to memory churn,
and that leads to more time
spent in garbage collection.
That's insidious because GC
costs usually don't show up
at the allocation site.
In fact, newer
garbage collectors
are so good at running
in the background
that you might never see
a GC-related frame drop.
Instead, all of those
onDraw allocations
are being reclaimed
on a different thread.
They're probably on a
different CPU core just
stealing cycles from all
the non-UI parts of your app
and eating up your
user's battery.
Now, all that is bad
enough, but it gets worse.
Think about the
kind of allocations
you typically make in onDraw--
drawing objects, right?
Things like paint, path,
typeface, you get the idea.
Now, what these classes
have in common is
they're all wrappers
around native objects.
And see, Android's 2D drawing
system depends on a library
called Skia, and Skia
is written in C++.
Now, a lot of the classes
in android.graphics actually
aren't much more than wrappers
around native C++ objects.
And C++ objects
have Destructors.
You have to explicitly call
the Destructor before you can
reclaim the object's memory.
Now, that means
running Finalizers,
and that's never
good for performance.
And the Destructors have to
synchronize on the native heap
lock, among other
things, so there's always
the chance that they're going
to block the UI thread for long
enough to drop a frame.
In other words, constantly
creating and abandoning
graphics objects is essentially
like telling the system
that you'd really like
your app to be interrupted
at unpredictable intervals for
an unspecified length of time.
So do yourself a favor.
Move all of those
allocations out of onDraw.
The refactoring tools in
Android Studio make this easy.
See, you use Extract Field
to move those objects out
of onDraw and into the
main body of the class that
can be reused.
Now, if possible, make
those fields static.
That way, you can
reuse the objects
between multiple
instances of your class.
That's especially a
good move if your view
is used in a list item
because in that case,
it's going to be
created multiple times.
Now, you might even
consider moving the fields
into Package Scope.
That way you can share them
between multiple views.
Moving allocations out
of onDraw is a simple way
to make a positive change
in your app's performance.
It's quick, and it's
easy, and it almost always
makes a difference.
Of course, it's not magic.
Like most performance patterns,
moving your allocations
won't make your app buttery
smooth all by itself.
And that's exactly why you
should visit the Android
Performance Patterns homepage
and get more great tips
and tricks.
And don't forget to
join our Google+ group.
And remember, keep
calm, profile your code,
and as always, perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]